ما يقارب 4 ملايين و500,000 شخص في انحي
اوكرانيا تضرروا من انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي بسبب ضربات الروسيه استهدفت
البنيه التحتيه للطاقه حسب الرئيس
الاوكراني فولدو ميرزنسكي
ملايين ونصف مليون شخص بشكل مؤقت من
استخدام الطاقه حسب احصاءات جداول الطوارئ
وتحقيق الاستقرار وذلك في كياب وفي 10
مناطق اخرى مثل زبريجيا وسومي وخاريف
وغيرها
ايضا الى اتهام روسيا لاوكرانيا بصناعي
وتجهيز قنبله وصفتها بالقذره مؤكدا ان
بعثه الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه تحققت
من الامر بعد تقديم الحريه الكامله
لعناصرها في العمل
حاليا حاليا الشيء الوحيد القذره في
منطقتنا هو اولئك القاده في موسكو والذين
يسيطرون للاسف على الدوله الروسيه ويقومون
بترويع اوكرانيا والعالمي باسرهين
تقدما حسب ما اكد زيليسكي ايضا وقد اجبرت
الجيش الروسي على دعم قوته في المناطق
التي تسيطر عليها كما في مدينه خرسون اما
في موانه اوديسا فعدت حركه السفن المحمله
بالحبوب والبضائع حسب الاتفاق الذي تم
التوصل اليه في تموز يوليو الماضي مع
تعبير منظمه الامم المتحده عن املها في
تمديد فتره تنفيذ الاتفاق